[موسيقى]
مليونان ونصف المليون عدد العاملين
بالاسود في فرنسا معظمهم من المهاجرين غير
الشرعيه او اللاجئين الذين فقدوا الامل في
الحصول على وظائف نظاميه ورغم ان الدوله
تحارب هذا النوع من الاعمال لكن نسبه
كبيره من المهاجرين تنخرط فيها نظرا
للعوائق الكبيره التي تواجههم من اجل
الحصول على عمل النظامي
في البرلمان الفرنسي على الجهود التي
تبذلها السلطات للكشف عن حالات العمل غير
المسرح
على الاشخاص الذين يعملون دون تصريح
العمل او الشركه التي لديها موظفون
بالاسود نحن بالطبع في حاجه الى مزيد من
عمليات التفتيش
ايضا الى التاكد من ان العقوبات راضعه
[موسيقى]
المعارضه غير راضيه
عن الاسود خاصه مع استمرار ازمه المهاجرين
غير الشرعيه
الحكومه لا تفعل ما يكفي منذ مده طويله
والموارد الممنوحه للسلطه تفتيش العمل غير
كافيه وسياسه الحكومه في غض البصر عن بعض
الحالات سمحت بازدهار العمل غير القانوني
حتى انها تشجع عمل منصات الانترنت التي
اصبحت بعضها معروفه بوجود العمال الاجانب
غير الشرعيين فيها نحن لا نريدهم ان يبقى
على قيد الحياه فقط بل نريدهم ان يعملوا
ويعيشوا حياه كريمه لذا يمكننا بذل المزيد
من الجهود وبشكل افضل